just three weeks ago the National
Restaurant Association released a rosy
picture of the dining industry sales
were projected to rise four percent this
year to a record of nearly nine hundred
billion dollars but the corona virus
outbreak has upended that widespread
restaurant closures and massive layoffs
have shocked the industry here to
discuss the impact this is going to have
on your neighborhood eatery and the
broader economy we are joined by Derrick
Thompson CBS News contributor and staff
writer at the Atlantic Derrick you had a
great piece out there and so many
quotable things in it including saying
that restaurants are the new factories
over 15 million people are employed by
the restaurant industry so in general
for the economy what does this mean
right now what it means essentially is
that this pandemic has slammed into the
US economy at a time when restaurants
have never been more important not only
to our economy but also to our culture
so two quick statistics the first attest
ik is that 30 years ago in 1990
manufacturing had three times the
employment of restaurants now they're
tied restaurants are indeed no hyperbole
the new factories the second really
important thing is that if you look at
Manhattan for example where you are in
the last year restaurants accounted for
almost half of all new ground-floor
retail leases that means that without
the restaurant industry the ground-floor
retail the face of New York when you're
walking around those streets is
decimated by half so restaurants both as
a matter of culture and a matter of
economics have never been more important
to us which is why I think it's so
important at this early point in the
pandemic that we look this problem
squarely in the face insolvent because
restaurants are sort of the they're the
early challenge that we're going to face
before this crisis sort of winds its way
through the entire economy yeah so Derek
the question is what you do about it we
just saw that number 15.6 million people
employed by the restaurant industry I
think the latest numbers from open
tables show that cancellations are
between 90 I think it's closer now to a
hundred percent what what hundred it's
gone it's gone so this is a huge big
question
I spoke to a Danish economist last night
about what Denmark is doing and Denmark
in many ways is at the bleeding edge
government responses to what could truly
be the beginning of a Great Depression
in the West and what they're doing is
this I have the notes down right here
they've agreed to cover the cost of
employees salaries and private companies
that are threatening to fire people as
long as they don't fire those people in
short that means the government is
essentially going to pay people to do
nothing now over the scope of American
history that might sound ludicrous and
absurd but think about what the u.s. is
essentially asking of these companies
and asking of US citizens it's asking us
to stay put is telling us not to go to
restaurants it is essentially blowing
the whistle calling the restaurants off
the field enforcing a period of
hibernation on America's face to face
services sector and as long as the
government is going to essentially
outlaw face-to-face services they have
to compensate the employees who are
affected by that outlaw so what I think
the government should do essentially is
to offer restaurants a bargain they
should say on the one hand but they're
going to beef up unemployment insurance
and pay these workers a living wage
whether they are in the restaurant or
outside of the restaurant whether
they're working delivery or not and also
I think we need to find ways of
extending liquidity to small and medium
sized businesses give them zero interest
loans right now so that they can
withstand this crisis and come out on
the other side as the same restaurant
rather than close down and change the
nature of America's streets
dereck real quickly before we let you go
here we've seen there's takeout and
delivery for some you mentioned
obviously the federal government needing
to get involved but is this the end of
the restaurant business as we know it I
certainly hope not
I certainly hope that restaurants and
all the restaurants that currently exist
can come back because God knows I adore
restaurants I love restaurants I know
that you guys do too I think that you
might see some innovation restaurants
turning from dining to drive-through and
turning into delivery services that
might bring forward the future a little
bit because in many ways delivery is the
future of dining out but I hope at the
moment that the American government
essentially says we've frozen the
economy we've chosen to freeze it for
public health reasons we also have to
freeze living wages for people that work
at restaurants pay them to do nothing
help them put put food on the table and
let's revisit the restaurant
business in three to four months when
this crisis is washed through us very
tough time but a great article as usual
Derek there Thompson thank you very much